call of duty advanced warfare is based
off of tremendous research the team has
spent the last two and a half years
really looking at the technologies that
are coming and this spans an amazing
amount of really mind-blowing new
opportunities for college any players
I'll do the advanced are sold man this
thing is awesome first you get the
bullet brass XO it's gonna make you the
coolest looking guy on the field and
with that the m1 quantum the bullet
brass version is a directed-energy
weapon this is a brand-new class for
call of duty you're gonna see this in
campaign co-op and multiplayer the great
thing about the m1 quantum is that it
uses a battery power is essentially
giving you unlimited ammo now you have
to manage how fast and how often you use
this weapon you don't want to overheat
and you don't want to deplete your
battery but if you can do that you
basically have no reload and that's
going to give you a strategic advantage
you get this really kick-ass XO and the
matching in one game changer for call of
duty
pre-order now and supercharge your
loadout with the advanced arsenal
you